we're coming off of God of War 2018.
how do you top that
how do you deliver something that
players will love maybe just as much as
God of War 2018.
the pressure was tremendous
my name is Ariel angelotti and I am the
senior producer for narrative my name is
Richard gobert I'm the story lead for
God of War Ragnarok I am Jody cupsko and
I'm the supervising dialogue designer
it's my job to shape the story along
with our writing team our narrative
director and game director as a producer
it's my job to help build a team to
create that content to own the schedule
and realizing that content I oversee the
dialogue production throughout the
entire titles every line of dialogue
that you hear every human vocalization
and effort and Grant our team touches
[Music]
like you no
we are not men
we are more than that
the responsibility is far greater
in the story of God of War 2018
we find Kratos seemingly having turned
over a new Leaf in the Norse lands he
lives a quiet life hidden in the woods
with his wife Faye and their son atreus
and the story starts with them mourning
her death and we learned that she made a
final request before she passed away
she wanted them to spread her ashes from
the highest peak in all the nine realms
he's scared of being a bad father a bad
influence and as a result it's made him
an absent father
his greatest fear is that he's past that
evil that's inside of him onto his son
you are too quick to temper you are rash
insubordinate and out of control
this will not stand
you will honor your mother and abandon
this path you have chosen
is not too late
Dave a friend Freya who is an exiled
banier goddess who used to be married to
Odin they meet mamir the self-proclaimed
smartest man alive who serves as their
guide and their Confidant and they meet
the holdra brothers Brock and cindry who
are a world-class weaponsmiths who end
up their main source of upgrades and
equipment
now among the enemies they make are the
Acer Gods whose leader is none other
than Odin someone we never meet in God
of War 2018 but who casts a very long
and Dark Shadow over the nine Realms
there are consequences to killing a God
why how do you know
how do you know
after Many Adventures Kratos and atreus
end up fulfilling mom's wishes and over
the course of that Journey they find out
more about each other and about
themselves and finally find a common
ground between them they become the
close family unit that Faye hoped that
they would become
in God of War Ragnarok we fast forward a
few years and little atreus is now a
team and they're back to hiding out in
their home in the woods in midgard
during the course of the previous Games
events they were forced to kill Odin's
grandchildren magni and Modi the sons of
Thorne Thor does a lot of the Lion's
Share of Odin's Dirty Work and as a
consequence he's a very violent unstable
personality at the end of the last game
they were also forced to kill Baldur the
son of Odin and Freya and that has its
own set of consequences he was a very
powerful chess piece for Odin one that
Odin is incredibly bitter about losing
Freya has vowed Vengeance against them
for the killing of her son
Kratos and atreus didn't want to kill
him they were friends with Freya but
balder tried to kill her in front of
them and Kratos had no other option in
the moment but to kill him to save
freya's life even though it meant losing
freya's friendship
[Music]
from every corner of every realm and
feed your soul to the vilest filth in
hell that is my promise he saved your
life he robbed me of everything
[Music]
his death is also foretold to bring
about thimble winter which is a brutal
three-year winter that is Then followed
by Ragnarok it's an apocalyptic war
between all the Norse gods the Giants
the dwarves and the elves and an army of
the Dead
they're all destined to fight in a
battle that basically ends the world
Kratos is understandably worried about
his son and what it means for him
you get to go on this journey with how
atreus grows into a young adult and how
Kratos grows into his next era in his
life and really see kind of the parent
that he's striving to be but the person
he's striving to be I find that tale so
incredibly relatable
we had started shooting plenty of
content before the pandemic hit in fact
the week before we all went uh work from
home we were doing a shoot I remember
being on and off that set running back
to the office and having to talk to
Studio leadership about what was going
down and how this was going to impact us
moving forward and those were trying
times for us it was a very unique
challenge because we had to bring in
actors and we had to record them and so
we had to look at different ways of
adapting our typical motion capture
process and dialogue recording process
so we can continue production and
continue at the Quality that we wanted
for our players and our fans we had some
actors stand in for other characters
actors who were already you know who
were like core to one of the scenes
might just be able to play a background
character in another scene to be able to
avoid a situation where too many people
were on set on any given day
we avoided compromising the story that
we were trying to tell as a result of
the pandemic and these limitations that
we had to deal with there were no
cinematics that we changed we still have
the same characters in them in the final
game we just had to get a bit creative
with how we shot the content our actor
for atreya sunny is a teenage boy and
his voice changed dramatically
throughout the several years on this
title I
fight anyone
[Music]
I just want answers we had to go in and
even out that performance so it sounds
like it took place over a short period
of time that that was a unique Challenge
on this one
the prophecies say femble winter leads
to Ragnarok
war is coming
whether the north Saga was going to be a
Trilogy or just two games was something
we debated a lot there were obviously
pros and cons for either approach
so we waited for Corey barlog to weigh
in and he did and he said let's do it in
two the consequence to that is how do
you wrap up the story in one game and do
Ragnarok Justice
how do we lead up to that and then have
a big moment at the end of the game and
wrap up all those threads this game is
bigger than what we initially envisioned
there's a lot of important story moments
that we needed to cover there are more
characters that we follow the threads of
and ultimately it ends up feeling
big and epic because there is a lot
there for people to enjoy I am very
excited for folks to see this Final
Chapter a lot happens we put our
characters through the ringer but we
also bring them closure and we provide
answers to a lot of the questions the
first game pose just all of the the new
combat that we're doing and the the new
interactions
um there's a there's a lot of stuff
that's happening in this title that I I
think people are going to have fun with
we all have our own personal ragnaroks
to deal with and this story is about how
you process that how you own it and how
you make it a part of yourself and grow
from it I mean we set some stuff up
um at the end of last game there's gonna
be some consequences this game we're
going to see how things play out between
Freya and Kratos we're gonna see how the
evolution of the family relationship
continues you got rock and Sentry the
dwarves who are kind of part of your
makeshift family now and there's going
to be some other characters that we
introduce that maybe gonna disrupt the
balance a little bit I can't wait until
players get their hands on the game are
able to experience how the story unfolds
for themselves we have I think an
incredibly well-rounded game very
satisfying combat beautiful and Rich
environments to explore outstanding
character art a lush and moving
soundtrack and soundscape it's the work
of hundreds of very dedicated artists
and they all have their own stories to
tell
today's theme song